The secret sauce that makes this dynamic relation between
the client and the server possible is this mechanism
called subcontract. It's sort of like the real life
analogy of off loading work to a third party,
you know, you give sub contract to somebody to
get some work done. That's the same analogy that
is being used here, in the structure of the
Spring network operating system. I mentioned earlier, that the
contract between the client and the server is
established thru the IDL. That is the Interface
Description language, used to create the contract between
the client and the server. And the subcontract is
the interface that is provided for realizing the
IDL contract between the client and the server. So
here is the IDL interface and the client
is using the server's IDL interface to make invocation
calls on the server. An implementation of this
IDL interface is accomplished through the Subcontract mechanism.
Put differently, subcontract is a mechanism to hide
the runtime behavior of an object from the
actual interface. For instance, there could be a
singleton implementation of the server, or it could
be a replicated implementation of the server. The
client does not care, and does not know.
And all of the detail of how this client's IDL interface is satisfied is in the
details of the sub contract itself. So what
that means is, the client side stub generation
becomes very simple because all of the detail
of where the server is. How to access
the server? Whether the server is on the
same machine or on a different machine and
are there multiple copies of the server? Which copy of
the server should I go to? All of those details are
in the subcontract mechanism. That makes the life of client
side stub generation very, very simple. So subcontract lives under the
covers of the IDL contract and you can change the
subcontract at any time. So, for instance, if you don't like
the work being done by one contractor, you give it
to a different subcontract. Same sort of thing that can happen
here is that the subcontract is something
that you can discover and install at runtime.
So, in other words, you can dynamically load
new subcontracts. For instance, if a singleton server
got replicated, then you get a new sub-contract
that corresponds to this replicated server, so that
now you can access the replicated servers using
the subcontract. And nothing needs to change above
this line. The client stub doesn't have to do
anything differently. All of the details are handled by this
subcontract, seamlessly. So in other words, you can seamlessly
add functionality, to existing services, using the sub contract mechanism.